Hi.
I'm Hadley Wickham,
and today, I'm
excited to talk to you
about a topic that's near
and dear to my heart,
code maintenance.
This certainly isn't one
of the sexiest topics,
but as your career in
programming advances,
it becomes
increasingly important.
And today I wanted to talk
about code maintenance
through the lens of
home maintenance,
because in many ways, I think
the tidyverse is a little bit
like a hardware store.
We don't build
the house for you.
We don't do the data
analysis for you,
but we provide you
the tools to do it.
And like a good
hardware store, we also
help you pick the right
tools and give you
some education about how
to use them effectively.
Now unlike most hardware
stores, we also develop.
We also build many of
the tools that we sell,
so we're also
listening to hear what
your problems are with
the tools to learn
how we can make them better.
I've also been thinking about
code maintenance and home
maintenance a little
bit more than usual
lately because of a very
frustrating experience
that I had recently.
If you don't own your own
home, you might kind of
think of houses as things
that just like exist,
but in reality, they
generate a steady stream
of small maintenance
tasks, and one
that I needed to
tackle recently was
a couple of exterior
lights stopped working.
And so I thought,
you know, this seems
like a pretty simple task.
This should be something
I can tackle by myself.
It'll take maybe an hour or
two and a trip to Home Depot.
Four hours and three
trips to Home Depot
later, I gave up frustrated
and extremely angry.
And so the first
thing I want to talk
about today is how do you deal
with that frustration that
comes up while
doing maintenance.
Like how do you deal with all
those negative emotions that
this thing that should
just work doesn't?
And when I'm tackling a home
maintenance task like this
and it's going wrong, I
often start telling myself
these pretty negative stories.
Like this is a
really simple task,
and if I can't perform it,
then I must be an idiot.
Or you know, I'm looking at the
documentation and the box that
describes how to
install these lights,
looking at what's on
the outside of my house,
and they look nothing alike.
Like the documentation
is utterly useless,
like it must have been
an idiot who wrote this.
Or at the end of those
four hours, you know,
I just tell myself that
was a total waste of time.
You will never get
those four hours back.
And maybe you are much better
at home maintenance than I am.
You almost certainly
are, but you
might have experienced
some of these thoughts
when dealing with
code maintenance,
when dealing with the fact
that your code that worked fine
a couple of years ago, hasn't
changed, but it breaks today
and now you got to do
all of this extra work
to get it working again.
And I think a really
useful technique
to deal with these emotions,
with these thoughts,
is to have some kind of
rational canned responses
you can tell yourself.
So for me, it's telling
myself, well, you know,
actually, I don't do that
much home maintenance.
It's kind of unreasonable
to expect that I'd
be an expert at it right away.
Or you know, like there's no way
the documentation could explain
what every single light looks
like on every single person's
house in the world, so I can't
expect the documentation is
going to apply exactly
to my situation,
but it should contain some hints
so I can read it and take away
some important messages.
And then sure, I didn't
succeed in the goal,
but it's not a waste of time.
At least I've learnt
in the future,
I need to budget more time,
and now I know where all
the various bits and
pieces are at Home Depot,
so I've saved some time
for the future as well.
Now this technique comes from
cognitive behavioral therapy.
It's a way of responding
to these automatic thoughts
with kind of balanced
alternatives,
and you can apply it yourself
in lots of situations.
The main thing is
to, when you come up
with these balanced
alternatives,
it's very, very difficult
to do that in the moment.
You want to sit down when
you're in a good place
and think about some of these
negative thoughts that come up
and how you can
argue against them.
I learned about this
technique a few years ago
when I read this book called
Feeling Good by David D. Burns.
The whole idea of cognitive
behavioral therapy, I think,
is really powerful,
because it gives you
this toolkit for understanding
how your thoughts
and emotions are
connected together
and how by changing
your thoughts, sometimes
you can succeed in
changing your emotions.
Now that's obviously a very
general technique for dealing
with frustration however
it arises in your life,
but I think it's also
worth recognizing like,
where does
frustration come from,
because I think at the
heart of pretty much
every frustration
is this conflict
between what you want to be true
and some unyielding reality.
And I think it's easy to
think like when you write code
that you're creating
this monolith that
will last 1,000 years, that you
wrote some code two years ago.
You can tell your
code hasn't changed.
Why doesn't it work today?
And the reason is while your
code may not have changed,
the world has changed around it.
And instead of thinking about
code as this kind of monolith,
I think it's better to think
about code more like a smoke
alarm.
It's something that needs
regular maintenance.
You have to change the
batteries once a year
and replace the whole
thing every 10 years.
Now let's start to get into some
more of the details of dealing
with change in code.
And this is a place where the
metaphor of the hardware store
starts to break down a little,
because once you've purchased
something from the hardware
store, it stays the same,
but when you use
code from a package,
that code might work differently
when you update the package.
On the whole, this is
normally a good thing.
This is like the
package developer
can come into your
house, replace
all of those expensive,
inefficient, incandescent bulbs
with new LED bulbs that
are much more efficient.
You get new features.
You get bug fixes.
You get performance
improvements.
But any updates to a package
also comes with a risk
that it might break
your code, and I
want to talk in a
little bit more detail
about how we think about that,
particularly in the tidyverse.
These ideas apply
in general, but I'm
going to talk about
the kind of framework
that we are using
currently in the tidyverse.
And I want to talk a little bit
about the kind of set of
promises, the tidyverse money
back guarantee, if you will,
that we want to provide to
you so that you can better
understand what is
likely to break your code
and what's likely not
to break your code.
And to do that, we
first have to talk
a bit about the
tidyverse lifecycle.
So you might have
seen this before
because the documentation
of certain functions
contains these
badges, like lifecycle
deprecated or
lifecycle superseded.
So the full tidyverse lifecycle
is relatively complicated,
but today I wanted to
talk about the four
most important components:
experimental, deprecated,
stable and superseded.
And you can kind of roughly
divide these in half
by whether their functions
in these various stages
are kind of out of
warranty or in warranty.
I'll talk about what that
means precisely shortly,
but roughly, you know, if the
function is out of warranty,
it might change at any point.
If it's in warranty, we make
some pretty strict promises
about how it will change.
So out of warranty, we've got
experimental on the one hand.
These are new
functions, new features.
We don't know exactly
how they should work,
but we want to get
them out in the world
so that you can try them
out and give us feedback.
This is the type
of code that you
need to have a pretty
close relationship with,
you need to be
working with it a lot,
because it's going to change
based on your feedback.
Now most functions are
on a stable lifecycle.
That means the developer is
basically happy with them
and has no major plans
to change in the future.
There's two ways that a function
can exit that stable lifecycle
stage.
It can become deprecated
which means basically
that it's a bad idea.
You should stop using it.
Or it can become superseded.
We know that there's
a better alternative
but the old function
is not going away.
So the first thing we're
going to guarantee,
the first promise we're
going to make you,
is we're going to try
and avoid as much as
possible to make breaking
changes in any stable
functions.
So a breaking change is
a change that we expect,
we predict, will break the
vast majority of correctly
written code that uses it.
So what are some examples
of breaking changes?
Well, firstly, if you
remove a function,
obviously any code
that uses that function
is going to break.
Or if you remove an
argument to a function,
any code that uses the argument.
Or if you decrease the set of
allowed inputs to an argument,
that's also going
to break some code.
So in general,
making a function,
the scope of a function
kind of smaller,
is going to be a breaking change
because code that works today
will not work after
this change happens.
Now as well as the
input to a function,
there's also the output.
Changing the type of
the output of a function
is also a breaking change.
If a function previously
retained a numeric vector
and now it retains a data
frame, it's likely to break.
So what are
non-breaking changes?
Well, of course, we
can change the output
because we have to
be able to fix bugs,
and this means that
technically, something
that's a non-breaking
change can still
actually break your code
if you've accidentally
depended on a bug.
So this is a really
important topic
that I may come
back to later when
we talk about off-label
usage of functions.
Otherwise, non-breaking
changes are generally
increasing the scope of
things, so increasing
the possible set of allowed
inputs, adding new arguments
or adding new functions.
So anything that
grows the interface
of a function or
a package is going
to be a non-breaking change.
Now sometimes, we will have
to make a breaking change
to a function that is
stable, but we're never
going to do that suddenly.
We're going to do it through a
gradual process of deprecation.
We're going to give you a chance
to find out that something
is changing and
respond to that change
before we take it away for good.
So what does that look like?
Well, let's take a function
from the tibble package called
data_frame.
Now we, probably I,
created this function
when we just started working
with the idea of tibbles,
and because tibbles are kind
of like a modern reimagining
of a data frame,
I thought, well,
let's give it a modern
name by taking the dot
and replacing it
with an underscore.
Now, pretty soon
afterwards, I realized
that was A, kind of
cutesie, and B, misleading,
because this function
doesn't return a data frame.
It retains a tibble.
So we decided to
deprecate that function.
So what happens if you
call that function today?
Well, you're going to get
a warning that tells you
it's deprecated and it tells
you when it was deprecated.
So tibble 1.1 was
actually released in 2016
about four years ago.
So deprecated functions
don't go away immediately.
They're going to hang
around for a while
so that you can find
out about the change.
Generally, the more
important or the more
widely used a function was, the
longer that deprecation message
will hang around.
Next, you're going to find out
what you should use instead,
so here you can use a
tibble function instead.
That does exactly what
it says on the tin.
It creates a tibble for you.
Now what happens
if you are looking
at some old code that has
hundreds of data_frame calls
under it?
It would be super annoying
if every single one of those
generated a message,
so we're only
going to show you this
warning every eight hours.
But it's also important
for you to fix
these deprecated
functions, so we're
going to help you find out
where they were by giving you
this advice to call this
lifecycle::last_warnings()
function.
There's one important thing
that you do not see here,
and that's an error.
So a deprecated function
does not generate an error.
It still works.
It still does exactly the
same thing it used to do,
but it is going to go
away in the future,
and the warning message is going
to encourage you to update.
So if you do call that
last_warnings() function,
you'll get that
same message again
and you'll also get a backtrace.
And a backtrace is just the
sequence of function calls
that eventually led to
that deprecated function.
In this made-up example,
we've got a function
f that calls g that calls h
that calls i that finally calls
data_frame, and this
is quite important
because it allows you
to narrow in exactly
where that warning is coming
from as quickly as possible.
We really do not want
deprecated functions
to be that one smoke
alarm in your house that
needs its batteries changed
and it feels like the beep is
like perfectly calibrated.
It's fast enough, it
happens frequently enough,
that it drives you to the
point of insanity, but not
frequently enough that
you can never figure out
which of the four smoke alarms
it's actually coming from.
Now the lifecycle stages,
I've talked about them mostly
in the context of functions.
They also apply to packages
in slightly different ways,
and they also apply to
arguments of functions
and even specific values
of arguments of functions.
And so for example, in the
next function in tidyr 1.0,
we wanted to update it to match
emerging consensus of function
interface across the tidyverse,
so we deprecated one argument
and we deprecated
another way of using ...
So deprecated
functions are functions
that are kind of moving,
deprecated functions, features,
arguments, things that are
moving out of warranty.
What about things that we
just kind of regret a little?
They're not wrong but maybe
there's a better alternative
available now.
That's the idea of a superseded
lifecycle stage, which
I'm going to talk about
with a little example,
because a few years ago, it
sort of felt like there was
this disturbance in
the tidyverse Force,
that a lot of people were having
problems remembering which
of spread() and gather() was
which and how do you actually
use them.
Like every time
you go to use them,
you'd have to look
up the documentation
or do some time
googling, and this just
wasn't happening
to the community.
This was also happening to me.
Like, I forgot how to use
these functions, which
seemed like a really
good sign it was time
to put some work into them.
And so last year,
we spent a bunch
of time talking
to the community,
looking at other approaches
taken by packages like a data
table, and we came up
with two new functions,
pivot_longer(), which makes your
data longer, and pivot_wider(),
which makes your data wider.
And overall, it seems like
that those new functions
have been successful.
People have found them,
or at least people
in this cherrypicked
sequence of tweets,
have found them much
easier to use and remember.
But just because pivot_longer()
and pivot_wider()
exist and are great
and easy to remember,
it doesn't mean that spread()
and gather() are wrong or bad.
They still do what
they say on the tin.
They still work the same
way that they always have
and by any means are some of the
most successful functions I've
ever written, probably used
by hundreds of thousands
of people.
So spread() and gather() are
never going to go away,
but we want to make it clear
that newer approaches are
available, and that's the idea
of this superseded lifecycle
badge.
It basically says, this
function, the development
is now complete.
It's never going to
get any new features
and it will only receive the
sort of critical bug fixes
that will keep that
function alive and useful.
And to me, the way that I think
about superseded functions
is kind of like the
idea of building codes.
So a building code is
a set of best practices
that you need to apply when you
are building a new home today,
and obviously over time,
those standards evolve.
So what happens if you
have a 50-year-old home
or a 100-year-old home?
Do you have to go
and update your house
to meet all of
today's standards?
That would be crazy, so the
idea of building standards
today is very important when you
are building a new house
or whenever you touch something
in your existing house.
So if you're
renovating your kitchen
and discover the wiring
is no longer up to code,
you're going to have
to replace that,
but you don't have
to rip out all
of the walls, all of
the wires in your house
elsewhere in your house.
And the same applies to
superseded functions.
Really good idea to use
them in new projects.
If you are touching
old projects,
if you're renovating
update superseded functions
when you need them, but don't
otherwise worry.
It's totally fine for
the old and the new
to coexist seamlessly.
The other place it's worthwhile
updating is if you're teaching.
Really important
when you're teaching
to be teaching the latest best
practices as much as possible.
You might wonder, well, when
are these superseded functions
going to go away?
And you know, I
don't want to make
any promises I can't commit to.
Who knows what
our priorities are
going to be in five
years or 10 years,
and what our resources will be.
But I think you
can get some sense
of how we care about
superceded functions by looking
at some superceded
packages, like for example,
the reshape package
which I wrote in 2005
and was superseded
in 2010 by reshape 2.
So because people
are still using it,
because packages
we've kept reshape
still working.
It's not getting any features
so it's not a lot of work.
We're going to keep that alive
on CRAN as long as possible.
So the same story for
plyr and reshape 2, both
created a long time ago.
They've been superseded.
We are going to keep
those functions,
those packages alive and on
CRAN for the foreseeable future.
Now so far, I've talked
about these life cycle
stages which we as the
creators of the functions
have control over.
There's an important thing
that you have control over,
which is how you
use functions, and I
want to talk a little bit about
the kind of off-label usage
of functions, because in
medication, off-label usage is
basically prescribing a
medicine for something
that it's not
formally approved for.
This is not illegal.
It's not wrong.
It's useful in lots of
cases because there's
lots of knowledge
about medication
that hasn't been
formally approved yet,
but it is a little riskier
than using something
for its intended purpose.
And particularly
for functions, it
exposes you, I think, to a
greater risk of breakage.
So what exactly do I
mean by off-label usage?
So let's take a little example.
I have got a factor
and I want to extract
the underlying numeric
levels of the factor.
Now one way to do this
is to use the c() function,
because the c() function doesn't
know how to handle factors
and so it just drops
all the levels.
But I would say that
this is off-label usage
because the job of the c() function
is to concatenate vectors,
concatenate or combine
vectors together,
and here we've only
got one vector.
So you or someone else, you
in the future or someone else
looking at this code, might
scratch your head a little bit
and think, well, what does it
mean to combine one vector.
Here you're really relying
on kind of a side effect,
an unintended side
effect of the c() function,
which because it doesn't know
about factors, it drops all the levels.
You're going to be much better
off explicitly declaring
that you want to get
the underlying integer
levels by using something
like as.integer().
Or maybe you've got
a data frame and you
want to find all the
rows in this data frame
where x equals 1, and you do
that using subsetting in R,
and because R has this fantastic
rule that missing values don't
go silently missing, you're
going to get a missing
row in the output, which a lot
of times is not what you want.
And so you might
think, well, I'll
just use which() to
get rid of this.
Now this certainly isn't such
an egregious off-label usage
as the last example, but
the primary purpose of which()
is to find the location of true
values in a logical vector.
So this, you know, it's hard
to know what else which() would
do with missing
values, but you're not
really fully communicating
what you're trying to do here.
What you're trying to do
is remove missing values.
And so in this case, I think
you're better off switching
to a function like
dplyr's filter() or base
subset() explicitly designed for
subsetting rows of a data frame
which knows that you don't
want to get those NA rows back.
And the reason you want to
avoid this off-label usage
is because the original
author has no way
to anticipate what you're doing,
and so when they make changes
to the function, it's much more
likely to negatively affect
these off-label usages
than the documented usage.
So another way of saying
that is off-label usage
is going to void your warranty.
All bets are off when you
start using a function in a way
that the author
did not envisage.
So how do you avoid it?
Well, the first thing
you need to recognize
is that recognizing,
understanding off-label usage
and what the intended purpose
of a function is, is a skill.
It's not something that
you're born knowing.
It's something you're
going to develop over
the course of your career
in R. And in particular,
when you start out learning
R, your primary goal is
to solve the problem
in front of you
and get the result that you
need, and that is 100% OK,
but as you get better, it's a
really good practice to think,
are you using functions not just
because they do what you want
but because they
do what they say.
And the easiest way
to discover that
is to read the documentation.
If you are using a function
for a purpose that was not
mentioned anywhere
in its documentation,
you're likely to be
in the danger zone.
But I think the best
technique for learning more
about the intended usage of a
function is to do code review.
So this is going
to help you when
you get your code
reviewed by someone else
because they're going
to look at that.
They're going to look at you
concatenating a single factor
and they're going to ask you
like, what are you doing here,
because the chances are they
don't know all the same quirks
of the functions that you do.
They'll know the intended
purpose of a function
but they're less likely
to notice some side
effect that you're relying on.
The code review
also helps you when
you're reading
other people's code
because you're going
to look at that code
and you're going
to think about it.
You're going to say, well,
like what is this doing.
And maybe you'll read a
little bit of documentation,
you'll learn some new
functions, and that process
of reflecting on
other people's code
is really going to help
you understand and improve
your ability to write good code.
Personally, one of the biggest
improvements to my coding
style, I think, happened
when I started grading code,
when I started teaching data
analysis at Rice University.
That process of having to
read other people's code
and think about like why was
this hard to understand really
made my own code much
more elegant and clearer.
Now while off-label
usage of a function
will void your warranty, we
as maintainer of the package
still want to avoid
unforeseen consequences
as much as possible,
and I think there's
a really interesting
unforseen consequence
of this transition from
incandescent light bulbs to LED
light bulbs.
And that is a few
years back, cities
started converting the traffic
lights from incandescent to LED
because it saved
a bunch of time,
and they don't need to be
replaced as frequently,
and they used much,
much less power.
But unfortunately,
the first winter
after this happened,
they discovered
a problem, that snow was
accumulating in the traffic
lights and blocking them so
people couldn't see them,
and this was because
one of the reasons
that incandescent bulbs
was so inefficient
was that they also
produced a bunch of heat.
And so now, previously they
would have melted the snow,
and now with these new
LED bulbs, they didn't.
Snow accumulated and there
were a bunch of car crashes.
So in the tidyverse,
we want to avoid that
as much as possible by
trying, particularly
when we make big
changes, to making sure
that there aren't
common off-label usages
that we need to support.
And I want to talk about this in
the context of a recent change
to magrittr, a
set of big changes
that improved backtraces, so
when you get an error message,
it's much easier to see
where in the pipeline
it actually happened.
There's much less
overhead, so it's faster,
and it is much closer to
the upcoming base pipe.
So I think these are three
really big and important
improvements, but
to get them, we
had to fundamentally
reengineer how the pipe works,
and our analysis
suggested that it
should be fine for any correct
usage of the pipe or any way
that we use the
pipe, but we wanted
to make sure there
weren't a bunch of uses
that we hadn't imagined that
we still needed to support.
So we did three
things, and you can
learn from those three things.
So the first thing
we always do is
we always run our command check
on all of the packages that
use our package on CRAN.
Now code in CRAN packages is
not exactly the same as data
analysis code, but it
is a very large body
of our code that is very
easy for us to rerun,
so this is a great
first pass to pick
if there's any major
problems with a new version
of our package.
And this is also, if you can
go to the effort of putting
a package on CRAN,
this also gives you
some extra protection.
Before any package in
the tidyverse changes,
all of your tests will be
rerun and we'll tell you
if we've broken something.
We also tweeted about it.
We tweet about pretty
much everything we do.
Following us on
Twitter is a great way
to keep up with the latest
and greatest changes
in the tidyverse.
But for changes
of this magnitude,
we also blog about it,
and so in this case,
me and Al wrote a
blog post saying,
hey, there's a big new version
of magrittr coming along.
Please try it out and let
us know what you think.
Does it break
anything in your code?
And in the process of
coming up with this slide,
I realized if you
don't use Twitter
and you don't use
blogs, how are you
supposed to keep up
with these things,
so we're going to add a mailing
list so you can easily sign up
for updates over email in
the not too distant future.
Now, when we did
this for magrittr,
we actually uncovered a bunch of
small and not so small things,
so we either fixed
magrittr to make this work,
or if we couldn't do that,
at least make it give
an informative error message.
But there were still a
few things, the trade-off
between the amount of time it
would take to fix them versus
the frequency of the
usage in the community,
and at the end of
the day, we have
to kind of make this balance.
That we are going
to pick these large,
positive improvements for
the vast majority of people
is an OK trade-off
for a few new problems
for a very small
amount of people.
Now, even after learning
about the tidyverse lifecycle
and the various promises
that we make to you,
you might still feel nervous
that for particularly critical
projects, you might be worried
that an otherwise innocuous
package update might
break your code,
and so you have
a fallback, which
is to opt out of the
hurly-burly of package updates.
Now this is generally
not a good idea
because you're not
just opting out
of changes that might
break your code.
You're also opting out of
bug fixes and improvements
and new features.
But for some types of code,
particularly code that
is run unattended like
code in production,
it can be a good idea to
use one of these techniques
so that your code is 100%
isolated and protected
from changes to other packages.
So the first thing you can
do is use the renv package.
Basically, what
this is going to do
is isolate each
project you work on,
give it its own
library of R packages.
So it doesn't matter what
you install elsewhere.
This project will always use
the same set of packages.
It also comes with
a pair of functions
that let you save those
packaged versions to disk
and then restore
them elsewhere so you
can run your code
on another computer,
and it will hopefully give
you exactly the same results
because you've installed exactly
the same versions of packages.
Now, because renv
works by giving you
a custom library of packages,
an isolated library of packages,
it works with any
packages, and it
doesn't matter
where it comes from,
whether it's CRAN or GitHub or
your company's internal package
repository.
But renv is quite a
lot of work to set up.
It's not a huge amount
of work, but there
is a simpler alternative if you
only care about CRAN packages,
and that's to use a
CRAN time machine.
So there are two
alternatives here.
You can use the public version
of RStudios Package Manager
or you can use Microsoft MRAN.
Both of these basically
work the same way.
They take a regular, roughly
daily snapshot of CRAN,
and so you can choose to
pick a day in the past
and install packages that
were on CRAN on that day.
Now this is obviously
much simpler to set up.
You just have to change the
repos option in your R profile
with R Configuration, but it
has the limitation that it only
works for CRAN packages.
So to sum up, you
know, I've told you
about some of my frustrations
with home maintenance which
also I think apply very
much to code maintenance,
particularly accepting that the
reason that you're frustrated,
that the reason that these
maintenance tasks can cause
frustration, is this collision
between what you want to be
true and what really is true.
And personally,
I found the ideas
of cognitive behavioral therapy
really useful for this, helping
me to identify my
automatic thoughts
and come up with more
balanced, rational alternatives
that help me think about
things more productively.
We also talked about the
four most important stages
of the tidyverse lifecycle:
experimental, deprecated,
stable and superseded,
and talked about some
of the guarantees that
we in the tidyverse team
do our best to provide.
So firstly, we're
going to try our best
to avoid breaking changes
in stable functions,
and if they are ever
any breaking changes,
we're going to do this gradually
through a deprecation cycle
so you have time to
discover that there's
a change and respond to it.
But remember if you're going
to use a function off-label
that voids the warranty,
because we don't know
how you're using the function.
It's much, much,
much more difficult
for us to make sure it keeps
working in the same way
that you're relying on it today.
Finally, if the hurly-burly
of package updates
is just too much and you want
to opt out, particularly if you
have a package is running
unattended in production,
you can use tools like renv
or the CRAN time machines
to isolate or pick a date in
time so that the packages you
installed do not change, ever.
So I hope you've enjoyed this
journey of code maintenance
and home maintenance with me,
and I'm really looking forward
to taking your questions in
just a couple of minutes.
Thank you.